how are these big oil companies going to
not only how they're going to handle it
are they going to allow that to become a
reality you're not talking about small
companies you're talking about a china
petroleum company
net income you know revenue is a 355
billion dollar company right you got
petrochina 320 you got a ramco you got a
shell 261 you got bp you got exxon these
are not small companies these are guys
with a lot of money with lobbyists
and a lot of people that are making
millions on top of millions of dollars
are they really going to allow the end
of oil age
you know what environmentalists miss is
that it's the companies don't have a
choice if you change your behavior so if
you buy an electric car if you start
using less energy if you put a solar
panel on your roof
if you behave more efficiently
they're powerless and that's the biggest
threat
that's my biggest frustration with the
environmental movement is they keep
attacking the supply side for example
new pipelines new pipelines are really
environmentally friendly because the
existing infrastructure is very old and
it leaks
but they oppose new pipelines because
the theory is if we stop supply
then we'll stop demand but that's
pretty regressive you know the point
being it hurts poor people more than it
hurts rich people
and you know it's pretty almost fascist
arguably to say okay i'm not gonna let
people supply energy because you
shouldn't be allowed to use it
what you should be doing is changing
your own behavior and that would then
knock the companies out where the
companies the companies are changing as
fast as they can
they've been busted in the case of exxon
for
trying to denigrate the climate change
movement which is really you know
nightmarish for exxon but most of the
other companies if you look at a chevron
or a conical phillips they just accept
that the change is happening
and they simply got to be more efficient
better players to survive
uh the potential for lower demand in the
future at the same time demand is not
falling demands hitting a record high
for oil and we're at 100 million barrels
a day plus which is it's you know
thousand barrels a second of oil are
being used
and to replace that with with solar
people just don't understand the energy
density of oil which by the way is
naturally occurring arguably
environmentally friendly because it
comes from the earth
uh where you're going to be replacing it
with solar panels which are often built
90 percent more or less are built in
china using coal-fired electricity
and forced labor and you're going to
tell me that's a better option than
using texan oil so that's part of the
esg
backlash it's really dynamic though i
must say you know this is a this is an
ongoing situation fascinating to cover
obviously but
what i will say tell you is the more the
government gets involved the more
they're going to screw it up and so far
we've seen california
uk
arguably certainly germany
essentially completely screw up their
energy systems by going too far too fast
it's funny you say uk and california
because i think boris johnson said as of
2035 they're not going to allow for
gas-powered cars to be sold they're
gonna ban it you can drive it but you
can't uh sell it anymore and i think
newsome announced it last week
on uh the same thing he pretty much
mimicked exactly what boris johnson said
they're gonna do it in 2035 as well so
the question it would make me think
about is paul this is your world what
percentage of oil is consumed because of
cars
what percentage is you know
can do you know the breakdown of how oil
is used around the world
sure i mean you know the single largest
sector of the oil market your market as
i mentioned is kind of elegant it's a
hundred million barrels a day a thousand
barrels a second
uh
10 million barrels a day alone is us
cars just us
so the single biggest part of the global
oil market the single biggest sector by
sector
is u.s gasoline which is used you know
really wastefully you know i think i
counted once from my son heading down
the long island expressway we reckon
that 80 of us pickups have nothing in
the back
you know why are you driving a pickup
as you know
the efficiency of the fleet here is the
same now today 20 miles per gallon as
the model t4 the model t4 was about 20
miles per gallon now of course you've
got air conditioning and dvds and what
have you but the fact is getting from a
to b
usage is very efficient overall
transport is about 40 to 50 percent
worldwide worldwide yeah about eight
million barrels a day in aviation is
very difficult to replace
they'll tell you they're going to use
burger fat in order to make biofuel in
order to run planes but in reality you
just don't have enough burger fat
um
so there's numerous elements where you
have green washing where essentially
they say we're going to use biofront you
know a renewable diesel whatever but in
fact you know the eight millimeter jet
fuel alone simply you can't run a plane
not that number of planes
uh on renewable fuel at the moment and
if you do it's going to be very
expensive and one of the key effects
will be highly inflationary food prices
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]